96 97 98
99 100. you missed 11 numbers
i don't need to be good at math i have
beautiful hair
that's the saddest thing i've ever heard
didn't try to read that book
i'm reading it again how come i clearly
missed something i couldn't find one
person who wanted to be my friend
did you look at the card inside
why that's just other people who checked
out the book
it's a list of losers like you who can't
find a friend
so so they're desperate and you have
their names
that's brilliant
now how is it that you can't count
[Music]
is that any good i'm afraid not i fail
to make a single friend
that sucks i have a tough time making
friends too
the worst part is it was important to my
mom my parents pressured me about making
friends
all the time so you understand what i'm
going through
oh i read that book it's excellent are
you into rocketry
i started with water propulsion worked
my way up to solid fuel then went back
to water after i set our garage on fire
nice i also tried to get some uranium
and build an atomic engine but that
stuff's hard to find
probably for the best well good luck on
your quest to find a friend
you too
if you haven't found one yet i have good
news
mom what do you know about the drug
prozac
not much supposed to make people happier
why
i was just thinking some of my teachers
might benefit from it
speaking of which you'll be happy to
know i made a friend today
oh well that's nice
but as i said this isn't for me it's for
you
my mother asked me to ask you if you'd
like to join us for dinner
why i was hoping you'd know
[Music]
i don't understand why it didn't match
me neither
evil nazi scientist did it 50 years ago
how hard could it be
can i help you sorry to bond you ma'am
fbi
we're looking for a sheldon lee cooper
george now
what these gentlemen are with the fbi
they want to talk to sheldon
what uh you fellas must have made a
mistake
sheldon's nine well someone living at
this address recently called a mining
operation in canada and tried to buy
uranium okay maybe it's not a mistake
it's ridiculous let's just go talk to
him
he's just a little itty-bitty thing he's
harmless
he's in the garage
[Music]
you